a coronary artery bypass graft or
cabbage is performed to improve
circulation to the heart muscle in
people with severe coronary artery
disease in this procedure a healthy
artery or vein from another part of the
body is connected or grafted to the
blocked coronary artery the grafted
artery or vein bypasses the blocked
portion of the coronary artery carrying
oxygen-rich blood to the heart muscle
one or more coronary arteries may be
bypassed during a single operation
before the surgery an intravenous line
will be started and you may be given a
medication to help you relax
cabbage procedures are done under
general anesthesia which will put you to
sleep for the duration of the operation
a breathing tube will be inserted
through your mouth and into your throat
to help you breathe a catheter will be
placed in your bladder to drain your
urine coronary artery bypass surgery
generally takes three to six hours
during a conventional bypass surgery
your surgeon begins by making an
incision in the skin over your
breastbone or sternum he or she will
then cut the sternum and move your
ribcage in order to get to your heart
throughout the procedure your
circulatory system will be connected to
a cardiopulmonary bypass pump or
heart-lung machine this machine
temporarily performs the functions of
your heart and lungs during the surgery
allowing your heart to be stopped while
the surgeon sews the grafts into place
one of two blood vessels is typically
used for the grafts the internal
thoracic artery in the chest or the
saphenous vein in the leg for the
internal thoracic artery graft your
surgeon will leave the upper end
attached to the subclavian artery and
divert the lower end from your chest
wall to your coronary artery just beyond
the blockage
your surgeon will then sew the graft
into place for the saphenous vein graft
your surgeon will suture one end to the
aorta and the other end to the narrowed
artery just beyond the blockage with the
grafts securely in place your surgeon
will use electrical signals to restore
the heartbeat and attach a temporary
pacemaker to the heart once your heart
is again beating normally the heart-lung
machine will be disconnected
your surgeon will wire the breastbone
back together and suture the skin
incision closed a temporary drainage
tube will be placed through the skin
beneath the incision two other types of
cabbage procedures have recently been
developed off-pump and minimally
invasive bypass surgery
off-pump cabbage is also called beating
heart bypass grafting because the heart
isn't stopped and a heart-lung machine
isn't used instead a mechanical device
is used to steady the part of the heart
where grafting is being done surgeons
perform minimally invasive bypass
procedures using specially designed
instruments inserted through small
incisions or ports in the chest these
procedures sometimes require a
heart-lung machine after surgery you
will be taken to the intensive care unit
the activity of your heart will be
carefully monitored if necessary the
pacing wires will be used to temporarily
control your heart rate the chest tube
will remain in place to drain excess
blood and air from the chest cavity once
you can breathe on your own your
breathing tube will be removed and
replaced with an oxygen mask the bladder
catheter will remain in place as you
recover over the next three to four days
all of these devices will be gradually
removed